[Music]
first of all I would say that it's
always been the case that there has been
two kinds of process there's been that
instant process where people are trying
to make work that has a huge impact at
the moment and they and and they don't
give any consideration really to to its
enduring quality I think you know in in
the world of books there clearly is a
sort of bestseller writing which which
exists for that quick hit you know it
exists in order to just you know to sell
a million copies very very quickly and
for everybody to read it on the beach
that year and then throw it away you
know and and I mean that's a perfectly
reasonable way to approach things but if
you do the other thing which is to to
hope that people will will read your
books
long after the moment in which they were
written then you have to bear in mind
certain things that that do endure you
know and and and one of the things that
the thing that indoors most of all is
human nature you know human nature is
the great constant it's always the same
in every country in every time you know
and I mean the reason why we sitting
here in the 21st century in America we
can watch a play written my 16th century
English playwright William Shakespeare
and it still says something to us is is
because what those plays understand and
have in common with us is an
understanding of how human beings work
you know what it is that that that that
motivates us for good or evil you know
and and I so I think that at the center
of the business of creating something
enduring is to never lose sight of the
human figure at the heart the heart of
it you never lose sight of the human
scale you know the moment you become too
grand to kind of
you know to wide-angle you know in in
your portrayal of the world you lose the
sense of that individual in the middle
of the crowd you know so in a way you
always have to know where Waldo is read
and and the crowd has to be about him at
the end and it's it's his presence that
orchestrates and gives meaning to the
crowd so so that's one thing I would say
that you that you that you really need
to have a you know have as deep an
understanding of human nature as your as
your gift permits you know and beyond
that I mean there are things that have
caused work to endure one of the things
is if you are able to capture a moment
you know cause one of the things that we
do as readers is we we read the past
through its literature so so if we want
to know you know if we want to know
something deep about the about
Napoleon's Russian campaign for example
we read war and peace which which takes
us into the reality of of that moment in
Russia perhaps has no history book can
because it takes us into the human
experience of it you know the lived
experience of it and I think more
recently you know a book like like the
Kite Runner would be a book that would
do that for the lived reality of
Afghanistan which is something that
people see on the news quite often as a
you know as a place where explosions
happen but what literature can do is
take you into the lived experience of
that place and that that makes it
valuable for a long time so and in the
way that you know now if we look back at
the so-called Jazz Age it's it's it's
it's very difficult to do that without
seeing it at least partially through the
eyes of scott Fitzgerald you know
because because he was so skilled at
capturing the nuances of that moment
everything from how people dressed and
what slang people used to what were the
things going on in their heads
so what were the ideas and feelings that
they were that were swimming around
inside them at every age has that every
age has a group of things that that at
any moments that that are you know that
are bugging people and that there and
there are orchestrating the way in which
they think and if you could capture that
moment then that can that can do two
things it can at them at the time that
you do it it can give the reader the
pleasure of recognition that the the
reader reads the book and says oh yeah
this is what it's like you know and and
then you know say 30 40 50 years later
people can read the same book and think
oh yes this is what it was like you know
so on the one hand it's has an immediate
pleasure the pleasure of recognition and
then later on it has that pleasure of
finding that moment captured you know
like captured in aspect and available to
people in the future so I think those
are some of the things you know that if
you're looking for work that lasts you
know that that that that are very
important I mean there is also just the
question of language skill you know
everything there is a lot of writing
that we still look at because it
developed our idea of what the English
language could be that's also something
of course that you know at the time of
Shakespeare English was in a very fluid
stage you know Shakespeare himself
spells his name many different ways you
know there wasn't there wasn't even a
fixed orthography at that time but but
out of that moment of enormous lis fluid
language Shakespeare created in a way
created English he created a way of
using this language that we all still
use I mean we all use hundreds of
expressions out of Shakespeare most of
us don't even know they come from
Shakespeare you know they've just become
a part of the English language so there
is that you know that that's ability to
to reimagine the language and by doing
that to enrich the language and and that
along with with formal innovation you
know another thing that that makes work
last and this is not just a literature
it's true also in in painting and music
and so on is that there are there are
works which make you see the form itself
in a new way you know in the way for
example in painting what the
Impressionists did which is to to try
and represent the way in which the human
eye actually sees rather than rather
than everything being in sharp focus all
the time that's not how we see you know
the way we see is we see something in
sharp focus and around it there are
other things not so much so that idea of
of depicting in oil something closer to
the way in which vision happens
initially was very was was rejected you
know in fact the term him when the first
impressionist exhibition happened
the term Impressionism was used as a as
an insult no it was that these painters
weren't really very good at painting
they could just give an impression of
something and so to go from that to have
those painters as being the bedrock of
any great modern art collection you know
shows you how work that was considered
to be no in a way outrageous at the time
in which it was made changes the
language change it changed the language
of art you know and therefore of course
has enormous enduring quality because
everything that came after it could not
have been like that if it had not been
for that for that moment so so both in
terms of language and form the question
of radical innovation often is is a
guide to to whether work will endure or
not and I mean in literature there is
just the other thing which is the well
told story you know it is I think these
days especially perhaps that elements of
literature is a little undervalued
people don't talk about the story as
being the thing that drives the work of
art but I've always thought that it is
that it's the that's the engine you know
especially if you're going to try and
write something kind of big and
ambitious you know if you're gonna build
a big car
better put a big engine in it you know
and if you've got a big car that's
underpowered you know it not very
pleasant to drive and the story it seems
to me is that is the big engine that
makes a big book work you know and and
as human beings we have a real narrative
program we like to understand ourselves
through stories you know and and so so a
book that that that puts story narrative
very much at the heart of what it's
doing is more likely to stick in our
heads and because we remember a
character and what happened to him or
her you know and we care about it that
the work makes you makes you care and I
think that's the last thing I would say
is the question of the question of
effect you know that you have to that
there it's very difficult I think to
create long lasting work in which people
don't care about the people in the work
say you there is a kind of cold writing
that sometimes does work it has a kind
of power because of its unemotional 'ti
you know but mostly people want an
emotional connection with with what
they're reading you know and and if they
don't have that it's less likely that
they're going to remember it
[Music]